in summary an increase in overall GDP
coming from agricultural labor
productivity is on average 2.5 times
more effective in raising the incomes of
the lowest quintile lowest income
quintile in developing country then an
equivalent increase in GDP coming from
non agricultural labor productivity so
if you want to do something about
poverty it's worthwhile to invest in
increasing agricultural labour
productivity now what's the situation in
agriculture we have very broadly
speaking to general pathways that are
problematic for both are problematic for
ecosystem services we have intensive
agriculture characterized by high levels
of pollution eg from fertilizers or
pesticides soil erosion and
deterioration especially soil carbon
being being reduced and biodiversity
suffers at all levels ecosystems species
and genetic with evermore increasing
specialized farm production on the other
hand we have extensive agriculture
usually in the not so favorable
conditions which leads to an ongoing
process of deforestation usually we have
problems of soil mining nutrient
depletion especially when on slopes also
problems of erosion so both both
developments of agriculture are
problematic to ecosystem services but
there's quite a bit we can do about this
the central challenge being increase
yields while not decreasing or even
better while increasing other ecosystem
services involved some widespread very
general discourses on the relationship
between conservation and poverty that
poverty leads to the destruction of
biodiversity precisely because people
depend on these resources and have no
other no other opportunity they / you
destroy them on the other hand there's
the contra contradicting discourse that
traditional societies and these often
imply poorer poorer people actually
ensure the conservation of biodiversity
because they have been managing the
resource over time in a sustainable way
they have a lot of local knowledge and
are well able of of doing so much better
than people coming in from the outside
there's also the storyline that
biodiversity conservation can lead out
of poverty by preserving the resources
that poor people depend on others say
they are interlinked and determine each
other so depending on just how poor
people how how much is still there they
are able to maintain it or it does
degrade others say they may coincide in
time and and space but actually have
nothing to do with each other and the
final conclusion that the potential of a
better understanding of the underlying
causes of both often of both poverty and
biodiversity conservation thus the
potential of a much greener economy and
less consumption oriented growth would
allow or would might take us much
further than trying to understand the
intricacies between these two aspects
you